hey thanks it's been a great workshop
I've really enjoyed every talk okay so
gonna talk about just standard pull
based active learning binary
classification and with label requests
from a pool of unlabeled data and we're
really going to sort of get into the
theory of from sort of this classical
like VC theory pack model kind of
perspective most of this is most of what
I'm going to talk about is sort of
buried in the proofs of this paper and
then there's a few follow-up papers some
of them are on my website and some of
them are published and others will be on
my website sometime soon okay of course
the the thing we're always contrasting
with is passive learning so I should
define that first we have a data source
the learning algorithm and some expert
these are the players in this scenario
and what happens is we get some
unlabeled data from this data source the
expert annotates the data and feeds it
into the learning algorithm which does
some processing and then eventually
outputs a classifier and if all goes
well we hope that classifier should
basically agree with what the expert
would hypothetically say if we were to
get new points from that data source of
course the idea then is the expert goes
away and we just keep the classifier in
contrast in active learning all the
players are the same but now that
unlabeled data is fed straight into the
learning algorithm and we let it choose
its own which points should be labeled
basically it'll choose one request the
label of the data point the expert then
identified labels that according to
whatever concept you are trying to learn
and then this happens again in in
several rounds so it's a sequential
interactive process
after a number of rounds the learning
out and eventually outputs a classifier
and again we're hoping that classifier
would agree with the expert
hypothetically on future instances from
this data source so the motivation here
is we would oftentimes sort of the wall
clock time or effort bottleneck in a
learning problem from the time when you
decide I want a classifier till the time
you have one is that you have to get a
bunch of labeled samples oftentimes the
unlabeled data is cheap but this experts
time may be costly and so we want to
sort of maximize the the amount of
information we're squeezing out of this
expert per amount of time or effort just
by focusing on only the most informative
or at least redundant given what we've
already seen samples and so the the key
theoretical question is how many label
requests are required in order to obtain
a certain accuracy and this is called
the label complexity we're most
interested in when is this or how much
smaller is this compared to the the
analogous quantity for passive learning
this has been studied quite a lot over
the past decade okay so they're kind of
two veins that one could follow in a
talk like this so one is active learning
gives you a benefit of a more efficient
search through the apophis class and
this is really the vastly the most
studied way of discussing the benefits
of active learning in general VC Theory
perspective and if I was I'm actually
not going to talk much about this but if
I was I would be discussing things like
disagreement based versus margin based
versus splitting algorithms and we would
get into some interesting issues of it
you know you've all seen like the image
of a binary search and this is this is
what we're talking about with that so
I'm only going to talk in this talk very
coarsely about this as I said there's a
decade of research on this and a lot to
be said but I'll only talk about it at
the very courses level that I can get
with and I want because I want to focus
almost entirely on the second benefit
which is only very recently we're really
understanding how important this can be
for obtaining optimal label complexities
and specifically when I say active
learning is beneficial for dealing with
noise I'm going to talk about
heterogeneous noisiness and this is
heterogeneity as the theme that's come
up in a few of the talks now actually
and this heterogeneous noisiness so what
I mean by this is some regions of the
space are more noisy than other regions
of the space and the active learning can
help you sort of detect that and adapt
to what regions are more noisy than
others and change how many queries
you're making in each region and this
this is actually something you have to
do if you want to get the the optimal
label complexities so will actually
define formal noise models in a bit but
to directly answer the question in all
of the noise models except for some
things at the very end that I'm going to
discuss here it's just non-deterministic
so so it's the probability that it's
different from the Bayes optimal
classifier so it's the the non
deterministic aspect
okay but I have conjectures about the
other case and I think the same ideas
will also give you optimal rates there
but okay so the talk is basically in two
parts the first part is it's a math and
formulas and things of this sort I'll be
stating the definitions and the label
complexity results themselves and in the
second part I'll be talking about the
algorithm some people will enjoy the
first part better some people will enjoy
the second part better if you're in the
latter category
don't despair when we get to the second
part you can it has very little
dependence on the first part I guess it
is so hopefully though everyone should
be able to follow and I want this to be
as you know interactive as it needs to
be if I'm saying something that you
don't understand and you want to
understand please interrupt and ask a
question okay so in order to talk about
label complexities we should define a
formal setting here there's going to be
a concept space see a set of binary
classifiers that may have an instance
space x2 label space its binary
classification so we'll just take -1 and
1 we have a target distribution and
that's just a distribution over the
instance space and label space and we'll
denote by ADA the regression function
just the expected value of y given x so
that's a real value between minus 1 and
1
and the error rate of any classifier is
just the probability it makes a mistake
on a random XY pair from this txy
distribution and we'll denote by F star
the Bayes optimal classifier which is
the sign of the regression function and
as I mentioned in the noise models that
we will State results for in this talk
the will always be assuming that the
Bayes optimal classifier is in the
concept space it was not an assumption
that we're happy with but it's what the
the techniques that I'm going to
describe work for although I have
conjectures about generalizing them
beyond that
in cases where that's not true it's a
gentle either because they're the
additional and Matthew pays at most the
the examples that fall in the symmetric
difference
okay can you repeat the question where
the Bayes optimal classifier does not
line the concept question is it is it
generally the case that the additional
label complexity that you would
potentially pay is that most the
examples that would lie the symmetric
difference of like you do this I I don't
see a reason that that would be okay so
you're not including the noise the the
parameter about the the sense I was
talking about the the misfit between the
model and the true target function so if
you include that I think that this you
get a different bound I'm saying if you
include that parameter in the bound
itself I think you'll oh I have a
conjecture on the last slide okay but
yeah I don't know why that would be
always the case but it could be
so it could be a lot less than that put
into it yeah I let's see so it could be
that and then also the randomness would
come into it so I right so on the last
slide if you still have a question about
this come back in so I do have a
conjecture that it's related to this
quantity but also with the noise
involved in it so it's the overall error
rate of the best classifier okay
okay in the learning problem right
there's a sequence of iid examples XY
Paris from this distribution but the
labels yir just hidden from the learning
algorithm and in the active learning
protocol we request them oh they're
hidden or they don't exist until we
request them however you want to think
of it so the algorithm chooses basically
an index in the sequence requests the
label and it receives the y that
corresponds to that x i and then with
that information hand it chooses and
other index and the this goes
sequentially for up to n times where n
is a budget that's provided to the the
algorithm passive learning is just a
special case of this that requests the
first n labels or a random and labels it
doesn't do it sequentially basically I
guess technically this is
semi-supervised learning but for our
purposes that it's the same label
complexity okay I'm just gonna talk
about label complexity in this talk so
I'm not going to talk at all really
maybe toward the end a little about how
much unlabeled data you need in order to
get these guarantees I'll just assume we
have as much on them on label data as we
need it could potentially be a lot but
that's it's actually one place for
potential improvement in these results
so just to define label complexity now
it's a kind of a pack style of
definition we say an active learning
algorithm a achieves label complexity
lambda which takes epsilon Delta and the
distribution as arguments if for any
epsilon and Delta if you take the budget
larger than lambda then the with high
probability 1 minus Delta the error rate
that's achieved is at most the best
possible error rate plus epsilon and
we'll be studying a minimum ax label
complexity so this is here we have some
family of distributions we're interested
in and some family of algorithms and
then we take the worst label complexity
among distributions for the best
algorithm in the family and we're just
going to consider two families so this
is all you don't have to parse all of
this basically I'm just introducing
lambda a is the active learning minimum
ax label complexity lambda P is the
passive learning minimax label
complexity okay and we'll instantiate
the family of distributions in its
various noise models basically well you
couldn't query outside the support of
the distribution for instance so for
instance yeah you couldn't query outside
the support of the distribution no the
support
okay the algorithms we're going to talk
about don't know the distribution okay
so gamma depends on okay
so the algorithm does not only support
but even though gamma does dependent
yeah this is just the description of
what guaranteed the algorithm achieves
it doesn't actually describe what the
algorithm knows
it doesn't even matter for the results
whether it knows it or not though so
that clarifies for okay so well there
are any questions about any of these
basic definitions of label complexity or
to lose anyone who wants to follow okay
good all right so we'll talk about these
in order to state these label complexity
results we're going to talk about them
in terms of to complexity measures and
these are distribution free
combinatorial complexity measures just
to keep things as simple as possible in
the talk one is very old it's the VC
dimension and the other is relatively
new the star number so the VC dimension
hopefully you've all seen in an intro
machine learning class right it's just
the largest integer such that there
exist the integer K so there exist K
points that you can classify in all two
to the K possible ways using classifiers
from your concept space the more recent
one is the star number would denote it
by s it's the largest integer K such
that there are K plus-1 classifiers in
your concept space H zero through H K
and K points X 1 through X K such that H
I disagree with H 0 only on X I among
those points okay so in other words you
can hold these the labels of these K
points fixed while flipping just one of
the labels and hold the other K minus
one of them fixed and you can do that
for any of the K points you can hold the
others fixed while flipping that one
label that's the star number and so if
there's no such largest one we say the
start number is infinite okay so I'll
just do a couple of examples the talk
isn't really about the star number
there's a lot of cool stuff that I could
say about it but if the we're talking
about threshold classifiers so it's just
some is one dimensional linear separator
basically then you know the star numbers
two because like H zero could be between
two points then you could flip
label while holding the other or flip
the other label while holding that one
fixed and you can convince yourself you
can't do this with three points in two
dimensions already linear separators has
an infinite star number so if you put
some points on a circle you could have
an H zero that doesn't that labels them
all the same and then for each one you
could have some separator that just
separates that one from the others so
star number is often infinite there's
some like decision stumps it's like
twice the dimension there are some
interesting cases where it's finite but
often infinite so that's the basic
definition of the star number and right
so as I have said if I was giving a talk
on the search through the hypothesis
class benefit of active learning I would
be talking about various kinds of active
learning algorithms and their relative
benefits and the thing is if I if I
really wanted to describe those relative
benefits I would need to introduce other
complexity measures that have
dependences on the distribution and the
target and or possibly some data
dependent complexity measures and a
bunch of these have been proposed in the
literature and I've listed most of them
here and the cool thing that happens is
actually in all of those cases if you
maximize them over the choice of the
distribution or the data in the data
dependent ones so maximize over the
choice of distribution or data set you
recover exactly the star number in every
case which is pretty cool because they
were defined before the star number was
defined so it's we didn't plan it to
happen but it happens
well I mean you can like for interval
classifiers that improves dramatically
but if you have two intervals it doesn't
improve dramatically right so I said
yeah you can always but those kinds of
things have yeah there's some other work
that looks at what if you can ask for
examples from a given class and things
like that you definitely do get
improvements from that compared to just
asking for labels by chosen points yeah
so when you say the worst case here you
are taking max over the distribution
yeah the cut you hold the concept space
fixed and maximize over the distribution
or the data set in in case of version
space compression and empirical teaching
dimension also maximizes over data set
so this is also convenient in the proofs
because I can use results that were
proven for these various complexity
measures to prove things about bounds in
terms of the star number I think so but
yeah I mean look if you want a really
good complexity measure the splitting
index is awesome
it's there's some lower bounds that
almost match the upper bounds it's just
a little longer
difference but I think there's a little
room for improvement over that but not
too much like there's a factor of VC
dimension in question it's a bigger than
or equal to the VC dimension but
otherwise the gap could be infinite
right so though with those complexity
measures in hand we can state some label
complexity results so just s is sort of
a warm-up let's talk about the simple
setting of the realizable case
realizable case here is defined as a
family of all the distributions such
that the optimal classifier in the
concept space and it's error rate is
zero so this is like very unrealistic
but it's a nice toy model that that
allows us to build some intuition in
some cases so if passive learning the
minimax label complexity is known to be
up to constants v c-dimension over
epsilon plus 1 over epsilon log 1 over
delta it's a fairly recent result and
for our purposes we'll just say that's
theta tilde D over Epsilon so we're
gonna sort of hide log factors to keep
things clean on the slides and active
learning the result is the minimum X
label complexity is roughly start the
the minimum of the star number and D
over epsilon small gap that you can
prove you can't get rid of but basically
that's that's what it is and the the key
here is that you get a better asymptotic
dependence on epsilon if and only if the
star number is finite and again if I was
going to talk about the other benefit of
active learning search through the
hypothesis class I would then say well
star numbers often infinite but you know
do not let's not despair we can replace
it with these distribution dependent
complexity measures and actually you can
show you can always get some advantage
over passive learning at least in an
asymptotic sense but that's sort of an
orthogonal direction from here on in the
talk because I want to talk about
benefits that you can get from the noise
so I'm just going to stick with the star
number as the the course is possible
description of that other benefit to
keep things simple so just to get into
that issue of noise still kind of in a
warm-up mode here this is a noise model
that called benign noise
so it's a set of distributions such that
the optimal classifier in the concept
space and the error rate of the optimal
classifier is at most some value new we
call the noise rate okay so the sample
complexity of label complexity passive
learning in this setting is known to be
the noise rate over epsilon squared
times the VC dimension plus the
realizable case basically and that's an
old result from vapnik in Cervenka sand
and the new result here is that it's in
active learning the optimal label
complexity is basically the noise right
squared over epsilon squared times the
VC dimension plus the realizable case
active learning label complexity so the
improvement over passive is that we have
multiplied this term by another factor
of the noise rate
you who have studied the theory of
active learning in some detail may be
thinking oh there's a typo on this slide
there should be another factor here some
complexity measure like the disagreement
coefficient but now this is actually you
can just have this which matches a term
in the lower bound essentially and you
have to use the techniques that I'll be
talking about in the second half of the
talk in order to get that kind of
benefit questions so far
so so that was a noise model but I
mentioned we're gonna mainly get our
benefits here from heterogeneity of the
noise and a really great noise model for
capturing for describing distributions
that have heterogeneous noise is this
super cough noise condition this is like
what it's designed for
to characterize those distribution so so
this is typical Toys has two parameters
an alpha alpha is really the important
one it's a set of distribution such that
the optimal classifiers in the concept
space and for any epsilon the
probability that you get a point whose
regression function has magnitude less
than epsilon is like epsilon to power
depending on Alpha so here large alpha
gives you a better noise condition it's
like lower noise and small alpha is
higher noise so this is saying the
probability so ADA near zero is a very
noisy point and ADA far from zero is a
not very noisy point so just to sort of
draw a picture of what this is if we had
like threshold classifiers on the line
and say a uniform distribution on some
segment maybe the regression function
sort of looks like a sigmoid or
something it sort of smoothly crosses
the zero to here's where it would flip
from the optimal label would flip from
minus one to one and if that's a very
sharp transition that corresponds to an
alpha that's up near one and if it's
sort of a very flat transition then that
corresponds to an alpha that's down near
zero the probability of the noisy region
the very noisy region would be larger if
it was flat and it's small if it's
sharply like in the picture
a benign noise can kind of do whatever
at once as long as the optimal
classifier doesn't have too large of an
error rate so it can just it can be a
threshold plus like some patches as long
as it's as long as everything to this
side is negative into this side it's
positive it can sort of do whatever it
wants as long as the area adds up to the
right number
the noise rate well it just all has to
add up to the noise rate and also to the
left has to be negative and to the right
has to be positive or zero okay yeah so
if you take a limit as alpha goes to
zero then the sort of the the a
parameter it's not assuming a forum
actually this is just for a picture this
is just for a picture but yeah I mean
this is anything that satisfies this
condition it just happens that sort of
the worst-case distributions put a lot
of noise a near separator often but that
only comes out in the analysis there's
really a lot of distributions here that
look crazier than this
okay great so that's Sabo [ __ ] noise
right and the behavior at zero
determines alpha because of how it
transitions that's just in the picture
again but yes okay so this has been
studied a lot in passive learning and
the optimal label complexity is known to
be like a times the VC dimension over
epsilon to the to minus alpha so as
alpha goes from zero to one this
transitions between that 1 over epsilon
squared kind of behavior to like a 1
over Epsilon kind of behavior if you
remember the realizable case had a 1
over epsilon times VC dimension so this
output parameter sort of lets you
interpolate between those two extremes
and so that's passive learning and in
active learning I'm going to state the
result in two parts the first part is
sort of the high noise case where alpha
is between 0 and 1/2 and we get a very
simple result their active learning gets
a squared v c-dimension over epsilon to
the 2 minus 2 alpha okay so what we did
when we took passive learning and
multiplied it by a epsilon to the alpha
or improved by a factor of 1 over
epsilon the opposite and just to if you
sort of blur out everything else and
just look at the Epsilon's what we did
is we took an epsilon to the alpha minus
2 and made it an epsilon to the 2 alpha
minus 2 so it's an improvement by x
epsilon to the alpha again in the
literature you all can see a bound that
looks like this times another complexity
measure and and this new technique
allows you to just just get rid of that
and get a tight bound
so that was the sort of high noise case
and this is the the low noise case with
Alfa between one half and one it gets a
little more involved in that case where
we get sort of a gap between our lower
bound and upper bound you could actually
prove you can't get rid of that gap but
I've written it in a sort of funny way
so you can compare the terms in the
upper and lower bound but it you can
simplify that upper bound to just be a
minute wean something that looks like
what we had on the other slide but times
term that's depends on the star number
and then we have another term here which
is just v c-dimension over epsilon so if
you sort of strip everything else away
again just look at the Epsilon's well
we've we've really nailed down
the dependence on absolute if the star
number's finite you get 1 over epsilon
to the 2 minus 2 alpha which is what we
had in the previous slide also so again
that's improving by multiply that by
epsilon to the alpha if star number is
infinite you get a 1 over epsilon which
is also what you get in the realizable
case if the start number is infinite so
we're basically again getting something
like a max between the strong
improvement and the realizable case
and it's always both of these are
smaller than passive right so passive
this is always bigger than one over
epsilon so even when the star number is
infinite it's still smaller than passive
and again we have to use these new
techniques in order to get this there
any questions about any of the that was
the end of the label complexity section
next comes the algorithm but it's a bit
time to answer any remaining questions
about label complexity the last slide
yeah yep - wait
okay great
so next is the algorithm so I apologize
if anyone got lost in the first part
come back to us now we're gonna have
pictures it's going to be great okay so
the algorithm that achieves all all this
magic is the following
it has a kind of a general outline to it
you have a something called get seed
which is basically an active learning
algorithm other active learning
algorithm but usually just something
designed for the realizable case you
have a subroutine called which we call
tick-tock it's an acronym
introduced later which sort of handles
all the queries and then at the end we
have some way to pick a classifier to
output call that learn that's could be a
passive learning algorithm or something
like that
okay so mostly we're going to focus on
the new part but in just in order to
describe how this algorithm functions I
better define for you an algorithm for
the realizable case and for that we'll
just actually pick like the simplest
algorithm for the realizable case for
active learning this is a disagreement
based approach due to comm atlas Ladner
we call it Cal from their initials and
just for illustration purposes I'll
describe it in terms of linear
separators but you should keep in mind
that everything I'm saying holds for
general arbitrary concept spaces so the
way this algorithm works I'm just going
to define it by pictures basically we
have our pool of unlabeled data and
we're just going to sort of draw points
at random and for each one decide
whether or not to query it and the
beginnings a little boring so I'll fast
forward let's say that we've queried all
these points so far and then the next
point we draw from the pool is this one
now something cool happens because all
of the separators the the linear
separators in this case all the
separators that label these as minus and
these as plus they all agree this this
has to be plus so in the realizable case
if you remember the they're all
consistent with the optimal classifier
so we can actually just infer that this
this label should be plus we don't even
have to query it we can just color it
ourselves or throw it away it actually
doesn't matter for this and then
continue draw another sample from the
pool let's say next one we get is this
one okay now it's not so easy because
there is a separator that is consistent
with all the labels we've seen the
labels at plus and another one
consistent with everything we've seen
labels at - so there's some disagreement
about what this label should be and so
this is the the algorithm queries it and
this is sort of the definition of this
cowl active learning algorithm if
there's some disagreement we go ahead
and query and if you think about the set
of all points such that there is some
separator consistent with the data that
labels a plus and I know they're one
consisting with the day of the data that
labels it - they sort of those points
sort of form a region colored like this
and call this the region of disagreement
and socal is defined by the property
that it queries a point if and only if
it's in the region of disagreement and
draws them at random and queries them if
they're in the region of disagreement of
course after you query the point then
you sort of implicitly are able to
update the region of disagreement and so
this continues you know you can infer
some labels maybe you get another point
in the region just agreement you query
it update another one query it update so
you can say over time it's sort of
shrinking this is I should say this is a
nice picture for presentation purposes
sometimes it's not shrinking so quickly
okay so
so if the region of disagreement
disagreement happens to be shrinking the
algorithm then queries less frequently
and that corresponds to an improvement
over passive learning okay at the end
you can just output any separator
consistent with the data so that's Cal
that's design for the realizable case of
course if you had noise and you query a
point you know you can't trust that
that's really the optimal label you
don't just want to update so you have to
modify this algorithm in some way or
it'll do crazy things when there's noise
so if we want to make it noise or bust
right so we want to make a noise robust
and that's where we're starting to move
toward that tik-tok subroutine that's
that's gonna basically make realizable
Caze active learning algorithms noise
robust there's the first attempt so the
idea would be let's say well here's our
own labeled data let's say Cal happens
to query this point what we might do is
take a bunch of samples nearby let's say
it's nearest neighbors and run a
sequential hypothesis test basically
we're trying to figure out based on the
labels that we're seeing whether this
region is dominantly labeled plus or
minus and there's some really great I
saw Akshay around yesterday I don't know
if he's still here but there's some
really great hypothesis tests based on
the law of iterated logarithm there's a
finite sample version of that that works
really well for this and then you can
decide eventually whether this is a
dominantly plus region or - that looks
plus in this case and then you would
just go ahead and infer that that's you
go ahead and label that seed point
according to that inferred label update
and continue this works great if you
have a regression function that is
bounded away from zero we call that
bounded noise but you can show that
under C Birkhoff noise it's it uses too
many labels basically it'll spend the
vast majority of its queries on a very
small number of very noisy points and so
it's just not going to work well for
it's not going to get those optimal
label complexities so in particular it
takes roughly one over the square of the
regression function number of queries in
order to determine the optimal label at
a given point because you're not making
any temporary smoothness assumptions on
the function that's right yeah so I
haven't I've sort of hidden some thing
that I'm doing here not an assumption
but an actual part of the algorithm
there's a metric and it's really tricky
to define it for arbitrary VC classes in
arbitrary scenarios but you can do it
and we can talk afterwards it's not nice
to state but I can yeah and that's
another place for improvement maybe
there's a way to clean up there make a
nicer metric to use in this but yes that
notion of distance is very important so
that this works
it involves the hypothesis class you
even use some on label data when you're
defining it buts data dependent yeah
why'd you load that detail where you
have you have to define a metric using
the hypothesis class and the unlabeled
data in a very careful way but it can be
done right so that that doesn't work
that basic idea just do a sequential
hypothesis test figure out what the
optimal label is and draw another point
and continue that doesn't work but
there's so in sort of figuring out why
it doesn't work one one insight you
might have is well it's spending a lot
of time querying very noisy points maybe
we we want to focus instead on the less
noisy points and there's sort of two
really good reasons for doing this one
is we actually care more about less
noisy points so if a point is very noisy
that's the regression function is very
close to zero you know getting the label
wrong meaning like not classifying it
according to the optimal classifier it
doesn't really even hurt you that much
like if it's a point four nine point
five one probabilities if you guess the
wrong label you only get a point zero to
increase in your error rate for that
location whereas some other place where
it's a point one versus point nine
probabilities well if you guess their
own label that's a point a difference
that's a big deal so you really want you
really care more about the less noisy
points and then there's sort of a double
bonus on top of it happens that this and
this coincide the second benefit being
that it takes fewer queries to determine
the optimal label on the West nosey
points so we're in a sort of lucky that
the points we actually care about also
take the the least number of queries to
determine what the optimal label is
there right so that's if the Russian
folks is very far from zero this is a
small number so we can sort of combine
those two ideas or those two motivations
and design an algorithm that sort of
adaptively figures out where the less
noisy points are and focuses more on
those okay so the algorithm is going to
kind of start by operating same as
before so we were running this
realizable case algorithm
and it's that's your get seed so it
takes a point let's say this one and now
we're going to invoke this tick tock
subroutine so this is tiered cutoff in a
test for the optimal classification with
surrogate points okay so that has the
convenient acronym of tick tock and what
we do is the same as before we were
running a sequential hypothesis test
requiring points that are very close by
and trying to determine what the optimal
label that dominates this region is and
but the change here is that we're gonna
have a cutoff so if we have exhausted Q
queries and still haven't figured out
with this test still haven't figured out
what the optimal label is we're just
going to give up and we move on so we
actually just saw that point away and
pretend it never happened
and draw another point I would say this
one and now let's say where we do our
sequential hypothesis testing this time
before we've reached Q queries we were
able with the sequential hypothesis test
to figure out what the dominant label in
that region is and we go ahead and infer
in this case it was red so we go ahead
and infer that label for that point and
do the update to the active learning
algorithm in this case to the region of
disagreement and we continue and then at
the end you just output a separator
that's consistent with all the other
samples that we were actually able to
infer the labels for and then we sort of
want to gradually decrease that value of
Q over time so that we end up focusing
on more and more on less and less noisy
points as the algorithm runs and that's
the that's what shifts the distribution
or the samples toward the whirring
mostly on less noisy points
this is the algorithm that achieves that
label complexity bound that I stated
earlier and yes I said you know you can
keep in mind this actually works for
arbitrary concept spaces you know I
showed it just for linear separators
okay are there any questions about the
algorithm
I think you might doing sort of be smart
about yeah yeah so that's the that's
from the that sort of other benefit the
search through the hypothesis class
there your your very carefully picking
points to to search more efficiently it
turns out it doesn't make any difference
in our bounds because they're using
distribution free bounds where like the
star number is in there but if you did
want bounds that have dependence on the
distribution you would be using other
distribution dependent complexity
measures then in order to get the best
bounds there you would have to be more
careful in how you pick here we can just
be kind of lazy because it turns out you
can still get the optimal balance
yeah it does I just said it I can tell
you what it is I just said you gradually
decree I what what the value is
you could start small and increase to
all the matters is that in the end the
proportion of each amount of noisiness
is is the right in the right amounts in
the data there actually let's see if I
there that's the value of Q so as the
sample index increases it goes down like
one over the sample and x squared have
some other factors
it's a bonus slide all right
I'm not actually gonna go through the
proof though you could feel free to talk
offline I did the query mechanism is
definitely a nearest neighbor in spirit
of course at the end we're outputting a
separator and so the the sample yeah the
querying is sort of nearest neighbor and
you're acquiring in local neighborhoods
but the choice of which seed point is
you know that has to do with the concept
space that you're working with and yeah
yeah so you're the particular algorithm
I show here yeah so you're outputting
something from the version space
basically right right it's it's a way to
denoise the queries of a realizable case
active learning algorithm okay I do I do
have some results for other settings
that that resolve for VC classes and you
can look at larger classes under
distribution assumptions just like in
passive learning so this is one that's
been studied if you have smooth
regression function in addition to
Supercop noise and you have something
called the strong density assumption
like you densities away from zero in a
compact regular sport passive learning
and get something like this an active
learning again improves by multiplying
with multiplying by epsilon to the alpha
using this tik-tok idea along with and
this one does use a nearest neighbor
kind of strategy a lot like what savant
talked about earlier and then it
combines that with this tik-tok idea
i've also been playing around with some
probabilistic Lipschitz settings you can
kind of also use these ideas in those
settings to
right okay this is that slide that that
I've been promising all along open
problems reducing the number button
label samples
yeah so it can be very large for some
distributions I think there are actually
distributions I'm still working out the
details of it but I think you can get by
with polynomial number of unlabeled
samples if you have linear separators
and a very nice like uniform
distributions the computation is an
issue even in addition to so a lot of
the computational burden here is just
dealing with how much unlabeled data you
need so if you had some nice data
structure to handle that this would
actually be fairly efficient but also
the metric can read which I didn't
define but that can be a little
expensive to evaluate but okay so here's
the thing I was promising I have a
conjecture that these benefits can also
be realized even when the optimal
classifier is not in the concept space
so here if we denote by nu C the error
rate of the best classifier in the
concept space with no other assumptions
I think you can get that the with active
learning the error rate of the best
class of the error rate of the
classifier that you can find it's the
most array to the best-in-class
classifier plus epsilon using at most
this many queries so this is actually
the same bound that I showed for the
benign noise setting earlier the noise
right square root of epsilon squared
times the VC dimension so Sandra this is
so this would include the model miss
specification error and also the
probability of mislabelling just due to
randomness
so this would match a lower bound there
so this this is a known lower bound
proven by Sanjoy and friends and Lina
and John I think we're on the i
wallpaper and then this is just the
lower bound from the realizable case I
guess modulo whether this should be plus
or at times but so that would be
basically optimal if it's true I have
some reasons for thinking it's true
which I could discuss with anybody who's
interested but I don't know how to make
these techniques work in the general
case to get this result but I think it
can be done
[Applause]
so just learning about high level
intuition issue with the algorithm so it
could happen that initially when or
whenever my query budget in the in the
test is higher I still happen to draw a
point that sort of less noisy so I
didn't anyways need that many queries
and then when I did get a point that
noisy my query budget has gone down by
that point so I never end up seeing that
any representative down in the noisy
regions of the space so is it just that
the quantities are set in the right way
so that the seebik of assumption kind of
make sure that you're like the
probability with which you can see a
noisy point is small enough or what
we're seeing too sure it's set very
carefully for for to make all these
things balanced I guess I guess that's
maybe the answer yeah so if if you if
the if it happens that I'm decreasing
this cutoff so fast that I miss an
entire class of noisy points because of
the choice of how I'm decreasing it that
must be a with high probability a set of
points that I didn't care about anyway
that they were so noisy that we could
just ignore them so there is actually
epsilen to the one minus alpha so if
your regression function is smaller than
epsilon to the one minus alpha
you can just ignore I think I think I'm
what I'm saying is accurate you can just
ignore them entirely
so just understand your algorithm is
kind of like a nearest neighbor
denoising followed by regular learning
yeah its nearest neighbor de noising in
addition to just realizable case
learning but with this trick of there's
a cut-off in the denoiser where I can
just give up if I if it's too expensive
and a decrease yes in fact there's some
literature on like nearest neighbor
methods that are compression based where
they sort of compress a neighborhood
down to a single point and then they
just use one nearest neighbor with those
individual points that sort of represent
a whole region of the space yeah maybe
maybe that you could use this in to help
out with a log or something I mean we
have optimal passive learning for VC
classes with super coffee noise but
there's a log maybe it can help with
that log in the upper that bond that's
not in the lower bound is this secret
metric off your CV for describe say for
an interpreter for something sorry he
said yeah so you said you have a hard to
describe metric in which you do
everything right and if I say take a
nice class like you know separators or
something yeah yeah I mean like I
mentioned that I kind of I'm still
working out details but I think there's
an efficient thing for linear separators
and are nice distributions that's just
using Euclidean distance I mean I think
a lot of times you can just use whatever
the ambience just even for a Duchenne
but I was curious what the metric might
look like in that case okay I mean I can
just tell you the metric it's it's not
nice but you just take some unlabeled
data you look at all the possible ways
that you can separate it and then like a
point here is as far from point there as
the number of separators that disagree
I'm going to that's the measure
robbers use this in other work also know
yeah having distance to do for someone
level beta induce
[Applause]